as a kid in college that's actually
doing both and killing my level and
killing it on both sides of the ball
Travis Hunter you call him a
generational Talent you know what makes
him special not only is he a condition
and he saw him after the game yeah
in the locker room dancing me I probably
would have been in the ice tub somewhere
he's just one of those generational
Thompson something we haven't seen very
often he actually supports my uh cause
or my case when I say I got to play both
sides of the ball he's a hell of a
receiver and he goes on the other side
and shows you what he can do at DB
playing space well making plays on the
ball him saying he ain't really bad and
everything now he's trying to catch it
he's definitely somebody special or
something we need to keep our close eyes
on Travis he plays both sides and I
always like to put my my GM hat on if I
was drafted in Travis Hunter
I would actually have him play both
sides of the ball like I would I
wouldn't take that away from him I
believe in you know he's done it all the
way up until that point so I would give
him the opportunity to do it in the
league too